I mean the famous you know Thomas kuhn's
structure of Scientific Revolution the
sort of you know predicated on uh
periods of normalcy uh you know
supplanted by periods of crisis when
facts don't agree with uh with with uh
um you know kind of the accepted
Paradigm and that leads to so-called
paradigm shift but these he said can
last for decades Generations you know
lifetimes and
um you know I wonder if layering in you
know it's like options pricing right I
mean options are you know you you have
to get the price Direction and the time
scale right so I'm wondering if if if
we're on balance
um not really capable of doing such a
thing in physics where you know the
direction the field should take and
you're in the time scale that's
commensurate with tenure with
somebody's got to step in and rescue the
community from itself
and it has to be somebody with money and
and to be honest I think Bezos was a
physics major at Princeton
or at least he was starting out in that
direction Elon Musk was one at the
University of Pennsylvania
Jim Simon's most successful hedge fund
manager in the world and has given a lot
like we're too tied to what doesn't work
if you think about String Theory String
Theory mopped up most of the best Minds
uh during our time
and it doesn't work and I don't when I
say it doesn't work I don't mean that we
didn't learn anything from it it wasn't
inspiring I don't mean that we should
throw away the ideas I don't mean that
it won't eventually
um be part of something but it doesn't
work to find the theories we need
and if you can't say that which is
terrifying I mean you know who am I to
say that Ed Whitton doesn't know what
he's doing but Ed Whitton as a leader of
the field as opposed to a researcher
took way too many resources in one
particular direction wasn't able to make
his bid and right now
those very wealthy people need to save
this field and they need to build Fu
money into the field so that individuals
don't have to not go under
Brian here's my problem
I don't want to keep saying this and
most of what I do
I don't like which is correcting people
gu is doing fine
it is being listened to I'm in
constructive conversations I wanna
I want to speed it up
I want to have conversations that I need
to be having we need to be having
conferences we need to be
you know having multiple I don't want to
take all the resources that were in
strings and become the same thing for GU
I want us to spread out get active get
excited and it's time to save everybody
else because they can't save themselves
everyone else is Frozen in place turning
on the news to find out whether or not
they've got a new virus or a nuclear
threat from Eastern Europe it's crazy
[Music]
foreign